und wir gehen zu einem anderen thema
dass neben den energiepreisen momentan
viele in deutschland bewegt nämlich die
situation an der deutsch polnischen
grenze
die situation einer deutsch polnischen
grenze ist nach wie vor dramatisch wir
hatten alle eigentlich gedacht dass bis
ende des monats die marke von 3.000
feststellung von unerlaubt eingereisten
an der polnischen grenze festgestellt
werden tag aktuell gestern lag die zahl
der feststellung von unerlaubt
eingereisten die über belarus nach
europa gekommen und an der deutsch
polnischen grenze bei
6.500 das ist alarmierend und wir müssen
uns jetzt dringend mal gedanken darüber
machen nicht nur die grenzkontrollen
endlich einzuführen an der deutsch
polnischen grenze sondern vor allem uns
gedanken darüber machen woran liegt s
was drückt die menschen aus ihrem
heimatland beck und was zieht die
menschen ins zielland was in diesem fall
vorrangig deutschland ja also die
deutsch polnische grenze betrifft ja
auch genau mein wahlkreis dass meine
heimatregion und in der tat das sind
schockierende bilder die wir da sehen
auch die stimmung in der bevölkerung ist
sehr sehr schlecht aber ich sage
gleichzeitig muss man dieser tage auch
erwähnen wenn wir dann jetzt sehen dass
leute sich da irgendwie zur bürgerwehr
aufschwingen ist das auch etwas was
irgendwie schockierend ist die antwort
muss der staat geben deswegen ist es
wichtig dass die bundespolizei da auch
verstärkt wurde und ich wünsche mir eins
ich wünsche mir dass wir ein klares
regime haben gegenüber auch illegaler
migration aber
grenzkontrollen können eigentlich in
unserem europa und das glaube ich ist
auch eine lehre aus corona und aus den
debatten dort er die letzte variante
sein wir müssen an der außengrenze zu
polen lösen und wir müssen vor allem dem
lukaschenka an der stelle jetzt mal das
werk legen das ist das allerletzte das
ist staatlich organisierter
menschenhandel in der klarheit muss man
sagen und da dürfen wir uns nicht
ablesbar machen lassen aber die
situation in der tat ich habe das gehört
von leuten aus meinem wahlkreis
schockierend wenn in den gemeinden dann
sich dort der müll ansammelt irgendwie
die leute streuen dort durch die region
auch für die polizisten mit denen ich
gesprochen habe enorme belastungen die
situation können wir so nicht hin was
ist mit den bürgerwehren die sie da
erwähnt haben wo bilden die sich ja das
haben wir jetzt her gesehen dieser eine
fall ausbrannten wo diese rechtsextreme
splitterpartei der dritte weg dort
aufgerufen hat wirklich dort eine
bürgerwehr zu gründen da wurden
irgendwie rechtsextremisten und dubiose
typen aus allen ecken irgendwie dort
zusammen gezogen so was geht natürlich
gar nicht und war alledem ich gehöre
jetzt ja auch nicht zu denen die da
irgendwie ein blatt vor den mund nehmen
wenn es um illegale migration geht ich
spreche das klar an aber man darf diesen
typen nicht das wort reden ist mit dem
zusammenhang nur ganz wichtig bei aller
härte muss man sagen da ist eine grenze
erreicht und man kann jetzt nicht sich
da so verhalten wie dies machen das ist
job der polizei in unserem rechtsstaat
und die müssen dafür warum ist die
polizei hier so zurückhaltend der tat
also ich meine sie setzt sich hin sie
sind ja jemand der der vertreter and
order und sie sagen müsste man nach den
gründen forschen also von mir als nach
die gründe die werden doch nicht anders
sein als 2015 gibt es
wirtschaftsflüchtlinge denke mal zuhauf
ohne denen jetzt das wort zu reden die
solche kritik üben das tun wir alle
nicht da gibt es diejenigen die für ihn
verflucht und vertrag vor vertreibung
fliehen und dann gibt es vielleicht auch
darunter wäre auch ungewöhnlich wenn
nicht ein paar kriminelle die es überall
gibt auf der welt so und die wollen alle
nicht nach polen sondern die wollen
zumindest aus weil ich der berichte die
wir gesehen haben vor allen dingen nach
deutschland und lägen über den umweg
türkei viele kommen über den umweg
türkei den den gehen den weg den sie
einst über andere routen gegangen sind
und dann muss man auch sagen auch als
vertreter der polizei die gründe sind
doch eigentlich relativ klar die frage
ist doch was tut man dagegen jetzt haben
sie jetzt haben die wunderschönen
angesprochen die push und pull faktoren
putsch faktor ganz klar die zustände in
den heimatländern der menschen die nach
europa kommen überhaupt gar keine frage
sehr schwer außenpolitisch in den griff
zu bekommen ja aber das gilt auch für
milliarden menschen die pool faktoren
sind aber viel viel viel einfacher zu
bekämpfen warum möchten dann die
migranten die nach europa kommen nicht
in polen bleiben nicht in ungarn bleiben
nicht in griechenland oder in italien
warum möchten diese menschen nach
deutschland und da muss man ansetzen und
gäbe
weicher unsere bundesregierung mit dem
schutz auch der nationalen grenzen
umgeht desto mehr wird das regime
lukaschenko unterstützt weil diese
sogenannten pool faktoren eben irgendwie
da sich das müsste dann sozusagen aus
ihrer sicht sollten die bundespolizisten
die möglichkeit haben an der deutsch
polnischen grenze
flüchtlinge abzuschieben gibt die die
bundespolizei hat die möglichkeit wenn
diese grenze notifiziert ist also
angemeldet bei der europäischen
kommission und vom status her gleich
gesetzt ist mit einer außengrenze ich
habe sollte das wirklich sein weil das
stelle ich mir auch die frage wir haben
eben von diesen offenen grenzen in
europa im gelebt viele junge leute die
sich für europa interessieren sagen ein
grund dafür warum uns die eu wichtige
sind diese offenen grenzen hat manche
oder können sich natürlich daran
erinnern wie sie an jedem grenzposten
selbst zu österreich immer wieder
kontrollen gab gab es dann auch während
der kroner zeit das ist doch nichts was
wir wieder wollen wir haben seit 2005 10
an der österreichischen grenze
grenzkontrollen das wird nur verdrängt
aber
nicht
selbstverständlich aber nicht ich habe
von nichts anderem gesprochen sie haben
mich wenn ich sage wir wollen temporäre
grenzkontrollen sage ich nicht wir
wollen die grenze schließen ok sondern
ich sage da wir wollen kann analysieren
sowie sie an der österreichischen grenze
passiert und da führt die bundespolizei
sichtkontrollen durch und zieht sich die
autos raus musste man dürfe das ist uns
schon ein und wurden terror polen dürfen
wir nicht weil diese grenze nicht
notifiziert ist bei der eu weil wir dort
lediglich grenzpolizeiliche maßnahmen in
einem korridor von 30 kilometern treffen
dürfen aber auch nicht beispielsweise
wird zurückweisungen der
einreiseverweigerung oder eine
zurückschiebung das dürfen wir an einer
schengen binnengrenzen nicht machen wenn
sie nicht notifiziert ist österreich ist
notifiziert deshalb haben wir auch die
befugnisse und machen das auch wenn
jemand der in marl ist jetzt nicht in
einem ausmaß dass man sagen könnte das
verändert wurde ja da ist oder wenn sie
wenn sie die zahlen
2013 2015 2013 mit den zahlen von heute
vergleichen dann werden sie schön
feststellen glasklar feststellen dass
der trend die entwicklung auf 2015 der
zulauf weil er sich seiner da stand er
nicht alleine ich meine die
zurückführung also die zahlen die man
dann liest wie viele flüchtlinge jetzt
von der österreichisch deutschen grenze
zurückgewiesen wurden ja die sind ja
lächerlich
die sind außerdem und es gibt beifall
kriminalität die man dadurch auch fast
und natürlich auch
identitätsfeststellung mit ich glaube es
deshalb nicht in wittlaer
gerade dran also wie sie dimensionen
gerade dass man sagen kann wir sind ganz
weit entfernt oder sind wir schon fast
davor wir sind verdammt nah dran weil
wenn diese entwicklung so rasant
weitergeht wie sie jetzt in der letzten
woche hat aufgehört die sich zufrieden
wenn mir das einmal einen träger in der
in der größten krise sozusagen 215 sind
über 10.000 menschen die nach
deutschland so wie viel haben wir jetzt
haben wir jetzt haben wir einen stand
von gestern seit august 6500 das kleid
im august das klingt aber ersten moment
eklig das muss man wenn man jetzt
sozusagen vor 215 waren muss man einmal
sagen 215 sind jeden tag über 10.000
menschen über den unsere neigung jetzt
ein erfolg des 3d das letzte mal rasen
vor zwei wochen es sind ja schon 3000
2013 hatten die kollegen in passau an
der österreichischen grenze um täglich
um die
350 bis 400 täglich das haben wir in
spitzenzeiten in frankfurt oder heute
auch die entwicklung geht dahin und ich
bin mir sehr sicher dass das ganze
höchstens noch einen monat hält und wir
dann die zahlen aber dann wollte dass
wir 10.000 am tag erreichen also hat es
bei allem respekt wie soll das
funktionieren also neuer der lukas
schinko der lukas schenk oder bringt
jede woche ihre warum mehrere tausend
menschen nach weißrussland wir müssen
natürlich gucken das grundproblem ist
natürlich dass der lukas schenkel dass
er im prinzip wirklich als
menschenhandel institutionalisierten er
verteilt wie sah die leute fliegen da
nach minsk um sich dann zu uns auf den
weg zu machen da muss man aus meiner
sicht jetzt eine balance finden ich sage
offen auch als abgeordneter den
grenzwall kreis hat ich will nicht dass
diese grenze zu gemacht wird da sind
viele grenzpendler das ist so die region
ist zusammengewachsen polnische ärzte in
unseren krankenhäusern ich will keine
festen grenzkontrollen was ich aber will
es werden die flüchtlinge dort
aufgegriffen werden das dann auch eine
identitätsfeststellung gemacht werden
kann das auch maßnahmen wie eine
zurückschiebung oder eine abschiebung
gemacht werden können weil heute ist das
problem die wollen sich natürlich dann
teilweise bewusst finden lassen von der
polizei um dann zu sagen jetzt stelle
ich einen asylantrag und dann ist die
frage wie geht man damit um dann gibt es
erstmals monate lange verfahren da finde
ich müsste man eigentlich ein klares
grenzregion haben und unser problem ist
seit jahren dass wir natürlich die
eu-außengrenze nie mit den eigentlich
gewünschten hotspots für
abschiebezentren geschaffen und das ist
das grundproblem wir können doch nicht
hier um europa und deutschland jetzt
eine mauer bauen wir sehen die
entsprechenden erfolge bei österreich
natürlich auch deshalb weil die
österreicher davon profitieren was in
ihren außengrenzen uhr an art maßnahmen
oder in ungarn mit der mauer mit den
sound nun gemacht worden ist deswegen
gibt es auch bei uns weniger aufgriffen
natürlich und deswegen ist das
kontrollieren auch ein bisschen
einfacher als es beispielsweise an der
deutsch polnischen grenze der fall wäre
aber die frage die wir uns stellen
müssen ist ob wir so ein zaun ich doch
tatsächlich brauchen an den außengrenzen
der eu wohl möglich und was frontex da
alles tun soll endlich mal ins werk
setzen das ist eine frage die wir
wirklich mal erörtern sollten und und
auch beantworten ist das ist glaube ich
das ist glaube ich das kernproblem polen
weigert sich bis heute frontex
unterstützen zu lassen
frontex ist immer das problem dass haben
wir den letzten jahren in der
innenpolitik gesehen alle verweisen dann
auch frontex und die europäische lösung
oft zu lasten unserer bundespolizei
waren ja nicht irgendein unsere
bundespolizisten dann zur front heck
schicken wenn die im zweifel den vollzug
nicht dort